what was it like
kind of witnessing what happened with
baby the last few months because you
know obviously rolling loud happened i
was there you know uh but what was that
like kind of just witnessing like
people trying to cancel them and and and
just that whole situation was crazy
it seems like he's on the other side of
it now thank god i think it was nothing
small to a giant like
just a lesson not everyone's built to
yeah everybody wanted to go through that
and make it out on the other side a lot
of your favorite rappers might have
stopped rapping deleted their instagram
facts or had a mental breakdown or some
[ __ ]
whatever i don't know probably though no
no i mean i feel like he's in good
spirits and i feel like like you said
man everything's a learning experience
right
and i know he's got some crazy music
that's got to be on the way because the
wayne record is crazy
he got to have some [ __ ] how's um
for you like
did you learn anything that you could
apply to like your [ __ ] off of what
happened with him
no
like you mean like did it affect me
no i mean like did you see kind of see
what happened and kind of like you know
did you learn anything from it that you
could apply to your own [ __ ] oh for sure
yeah so i learned off everything else
like i learned on like my mistakes i
learned off i wa i literally like a
watch somebody else make a mistake and
try to like oh i gotta yeah
yeah
i gotta go that way because that that
way wasn't it like i'm off my own
mistakes too though
but i ain't really see that as nothing
wrong but i just you feel me like
you know
this [ __ ] is what it is yeah but you see
how he
he stepped on top of that nah for sure